this is a tough one usually when you say
i want to talk about so-and-so you know
either half a dozen things immediately
spring into my mind or i kind of think
about it and then i go away and read a
couple of journal articles and you know
find out a bit about the magnetic field
of mars or whatever it is
but earth is simultaneously there's too
little to say and too much to say in
that you know obviously there's masses
and masses of things you could talk
about about the earth
um but actually you know most people
know about most of them already but
there are several characteristics about
earth that make it unique among the
other planets so among the terrestrial
planets which are mercury venus earth
and mars earth happens to be the biggest
it's the most massive it's the most
dense so it has more stuff smashed into
its volume than the other planets this
is the first picture ever taken
off the earth from mars so the one of
the probes turned around and took a
photo of of the earth and you can see
this tiny speck in the middle and that's
the earth seen from mars you know as an
astronomical object earth really isn't
that spectacular you know it's a sort of
middle-sized planet in the somewhere in
the middle of the solar system so from
an astronomical point of view again
apart from the fact that you know it's
the only place that we know about and
life in the in the universe
there really isn't that much and that's
such a headline item that after that i'm
struggling a bit to think of anything
interesting to say about the planet that
we have to live on it also has tectonic
activity so the crust the pieces of the
crust are split up into chunks and they
move around which we feel as earthquakes
the the twin of the earth is venus right
it's planet very very like the earth in
a lot of ways
uh it's very non-conducive to life on
venus because it's you know way way
hotter has this runaway greenhouse
effect at all but if you were just
looking at planets and comparing them
you would see two fairly cloud-covered
reasonably warm planets
with rocky cores and magnetic fields in
their middle and so on and if you were
really that uninspired by life there
wasn't really anything that would make
you pick the earth out as the most
spectacular place to visit in the solar
system
the interior of earth we can study a bit
because we actually live here so we can
feel how the planet moves around there's
a solid iron core and then there's a
liquid core around that and then there's
a mantle and then there's the crust on
the outside so when the planet formed
from the solar nebula it was probably
mostly molten
iron and other chemicals and things
built up and so it stayed liquid but
probably after 10 or 20 million years
the outer crust cooled and solidified so
that's where we got the crust but the
inner part stayed very hot
it's got quite a big moon hasn't it
that's unusual yeah that probably is the
single thing that's most different about
it i guess you know something in the
solar system has to have the biggest
moon relative to the size of the planet
and actually even that's not quite true
because pluto's moon is pretty big
compared to it as well but so maybe yeah
maybe even the moon wouldn't stand out
that much as a you know a spectacular
feature of the earth because there's
moons all over the solar system maybe
people would notice that we only have
one you know most planets have more than
one is the outer planets do this is a
very famous picture it's actually tilted
it should be 90 degrees
switched
counterclockwise rotated
this is probably the most famous picture
of the earth and i think it's called the
most printed picture ever made this is
taken by
apollo 8. so this is not from the
surface of the moon
but from the orbiter around it and this
is basically an earth rise so
again i'm struggling to find anything
spectacular to say about the earth other
than the fact we're here and that kind
of sounds a bit egotistical really if
you were actually flying over earth and
you were looking at it it would look
quite interesting people call it the
blue marble so you see oceans this deep
blue about 70 percent of the earth is
covered in oceans and you also see the
white clouds that's pretty unique to
earth the water vapor condenses into
these clouds and so we get this nice
water cycle and then we've got these
land masses and you see some brighter
parts where it's covered with sand and
desert and the green portions where we
actually have trees and photosynthesis
happening
so this is a pretty unique view of earth
from above so earth has seasons but
again that doesn't really make it stand
out in the in the solar system in that
you know most so what causes the seasons
is the fact that the earth's uh axis is
tilted relative to its orbit around so
that sometimes it's leaning towards the
sun sometimes it's leading away from the
sun
but other other planets do exactly the
same thing so again there's not even
seasonal variations is not something
that's unique to the earth um this is a
picture weight which i think is really
impressive
um because it's it's taken i think from
the space station and it's a
sunrise
behind the earth and what you can see is
basically you can see a bit the
curvature of the earth
and what you see is the atmosphere being
lit by the sun in the background
and you can really see how thin this
layer actually is the atmosphere is only
like 100 kilometers thick
i have read some people suggest that how
do we know there's not another earth
another planet exactly the same as ours
on the exact opposite side of the sun
going around at the same speed so we
never see it because it's on the other
side of the sun it's been a popular one
it's been around in science fiction
since time immemorial and you know you
look on your favorite conspiracy theory
website you'll find out about it
um we know there isn't and and well part
of the reason we know we there isn't
was if it would be pretty unlikely to
actually end up with a planet down there
but now we have much more direct
evidence because we of course if you
it's true that if there were a planet
exactly around the other side of the of
the sun following exactly a sort of
mirrored orbit so it kept pace with us
and when the earth slows down on its
orbit this one slows down as well and so
on we wouldn't be able to see it we
would however be able to detect its
gravitational influence on the other
planets just as we can detect the
earth's influence on gravitational
influence on the other planets it's not
there and actually even more directly
than that of course yes sitting on the
earth we can't see what's on the other
side of the sun but we sent spend plenty
of probes out into space now and they've
looked and there's nothing at all there
there's nothing to see so there is no
mirror earth on the other side of the
sun